well that was the plan but sometimes
weather just won't let you be great oh
my god of course
Kim Kardashian and her girls didn't end
up at Usher's concert in Vegas for her
birthday instead they found themselves
at In-N-Out Burger
you just gotta roll with it let's take a
look at how Kim's 42nd birthday
celebration all went down on Friday
Kim's actual birthday she had a
beautiful candlelit dinner at Nobu she
shared a video trolling her mom Chris
during her birthday speech
wait you sent Chloe the same text what
you sent Chloe the same text
let her finish you are somebody that um
I'm in awe of every single day the way
you handle every single thing in life
you handle all of us you handle your
kids you handle your life you handle
everything that comes your way it's just
so interesting to see it from the inside
out and really get a glimpse of what
happens and how they all balance what
they do fast forward to Saturday
Kim her BFFs and the filming crew for
who lose the Kardashians head to Sin
City
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
we are going to tell you guys
clearly Kim was unaware of the official
plans but it didn't take her long to put
two and two together Vegas and Usher
playing in the background
I should have guessed the Usher music
like I was like wait a minute we're
going to see Usher and Kim who famously
isn't a drinker got the party started by
throwing back a jello shot
yeah yeah they're really good so good
but shortly after they started turning
up they got hit with some disappointing
news
Kim shares this video explaining that
the winds were out of control and they
couldn't land safely in Vegas after
trying two airports they had to head
back home yep Kim still documented what
could have been from the night she
shared this video of the stunning setup
she had for dinner at Carbone and videos
from inside the concert
[Music]
yeah the vids came courtesy of Lala
Anthony who traveled from NYC to
surprise Kim and still went solo
representing for the squad and spirit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Kim admit it the fomo was real you know
I think you have to have a sense of
humor so while Lala jammed out with
Usher Kim and her crew headed to one of
the birthday girls faves in and out
burger cheeseburger meat cheese I'm not
only a cheeseburger
cheeseburger
and then three cheese fries after in and
out she indulged even more captioning
this photo quote the jello shots
continue on the party bus to Nowhere why
not but overall it seems like a solid
birthday for Kim who's been celebrating
all week before her Vegas plans got
thwarted Kim received a lot of love from
her Inner Circle the mama for sharing
tons of video of all the flowers she was
sent but perhaps the most meaningful
came from her daughter North who posted
this video as a tribute to her mom
North captioning it quote mom's birthday
tick tock
[Music]